hey youtubers is charlie so there been a
lot of rumors flying around about stuff
going on on arrow new villains coming
into the end of the season characters
dying so I thought it was really
relevant to do a Batman death in the
family explainer video so this is
primarily gonna be Batman death in the
family from the comics and then I'll
explain how I think that arrow might be
adapting some of that so here we go
Batman death in the family careful for
spoilers definitely one of the top 10
Batman stories of all time maybe not one
of the top five but definitely one of
the top 10 it was written by jim Starlin
same guy who created this guy Thanos
infinity saga all that awesome Avengers
stuff we were talking about earlier
today what happened is is in the late
80s DC wanted to bring in a new Robin
and they had just gotten done with a
bunch of Frank Miller runs that went on
to be recognized as some of the best
Batman stories of all time I mean Frank
Miller one of the best comic book
writers of all time so naturally when he
writes a Batman story it's gonna be one
of the top five so 1980s in general just
defined by Frank Miller's tone his dark
gritty Batman tone that started with
Dark Knight Returns he wrote that in
1986 sac Snyder worked with Frank Miller
a lot on a lot of his movies is adapting
portions of that for Batman V Superman
the year after he did that in 1987 he
did Batman year one so right away to the
best Batman stories of all time
then after that came son of the demon
that storyline where Batman learned he
had a love child with Talia al Ghul be
sure to open a tab for lazarus pit it's
going to be important for later so three
big WTF s in a row how the hell do you
follow that up the short answer is that
you can't follow that but jim Starlin
came close he killed Robin on the list
of WTF moments that you can give
characters they're really only a few
trump cards one you kill them like death
of Superman or Bane breakin Batman's
back at nightfall or two you kill
someone they love someone innocent that
they were supposed to protect
enter Jason Todd the death in the
families storyline starts out with Jason
Todd trying to track down his real-life
mother he learns that the woman he
thinks is his mother isn't his
biological mother
he and Batman go all over the world
trying to find her end up tracking her
down to an aid station in Ethiopia
working as a doctor turns out she had
fled the United States years ago because
she'd been performing illegal abortions
on teenagers in one of them died on the
table so she got blacklisted
escaped her past so she fled Ethiopia
it's only implied that she was
performing abortions the comic said
illegal operations so it could have been
something more sinister because we
learned that Jason Todd's mother was a
little bit Shady eventually Jason Todd
tracks his mother down but finds out
that the Joker had found her first and
has been blackmailing her into this big
plot to try and create this giant
laughing gas bomb we also learned that
his mother's been embezzling funds in
order to cover it up she hands him over
to the Joker your own mother handing you
over to Batman's worst villain things go
from bad to worse as you can imagine the
Joker wants to set off a giant dirty
bomb of laughing gas so in order to
cover his tracks he ties up Jason and
his mother leaves them in sets a bomb
off it's actually kind of worse than
that whenever his mother handed him over
to the Joker she watched as he
mercilessly beat him bloody with a
crowbar remember this is the 1980s
we're following Frank Miller so we have
to make it really bloody really dark we
don't want people to fall asleep while
they're reading this comic Batman learns
what's going on rushes in but gets there
too late he learns that even though his
mother betrayed him Jason died trying to
save her this sets the stage for Tim
Drake to become the new Robin he and
Nightwing decide that Batman always
needs a Robin so he becomes the new one
so it was this big WTF comic-book event
that made everybody crap their pants and
allowed DC to bring in a new Robin
character already I'm sure you guys are
feeling really good about all those air
rumors now so what what is all of this
death in the family stuff have to do
with arrow season 3 let's look at some
really ominous evidence both Stephen
Amell and Colton Haynes posted a bunch
of ominous stuff while they were filming
episode 19 titled Broken Arrow that
title sounds really creepy already
somebody on Team arrow could end up
broken team arrow itself could break
apart it could mean a number of things
but let's look at these messages it
started with this picture of Oliver Roy
and black Canary on a rooftop with the
note saying that this was just the last
time something was happening like the
last time ever that also could mean a
lot of things like the last time they
all work together as a team
the last time they all wear those
costumes like people could be getting
costume upgrades or it could be the last
time they're working with one of the
actors and just for some added context
the person taking the picture
who you don't see is Paul Blackthorne
who plays Quentin so that's just the
beginning then other people started
posting some stuff Colton Haynes posted
this sad face picture with Emily BETT
apparently she came over to cheer him up
he was down to the dumps not only is she
really awesome but why is he so sad all
of a sudden then Stephen Amell posted
this tweet about saying goodbyes like
final goodbyes Colton also posted
something similar about doing really
difficult emotional scenes definitely a
tone of finality in the way that they're
talking about this whatever it is that
they've been doing so that does not
confirm that anyone is dying that
doesn't necessarily mean anyone's dying
it just means the teen arrow is going to
be changing significantly before the end
of the season and going into season 4
why do things have to change you scream
I'm sure you're all screaming right now
mostly so the narrative can stay
interesting like their number one goal
is just to make interesting TV from a
practical perspective team arrow always
brings in new characters every year in
order to make room they have to get rid
of the old ones characters have to leave
like Ray Palmer going off on a spin-off
show and characters had to die like Sara
Laurel got her spot in the arrow cave
because Sara died otherwise she would
not have become Black Canary so old
characters make way for new characters
in various ways let's wait to talk about
Katie lots going on the spin-off show
that's like a whole other story
they still haven't explained how she's
coming back to life regardless of all
the extra stuff something is probably
happening to Roy that will inspire Thea
to take the speedy mantle even though
Oliver totally calls her that all the
time already in really happy news Willa
Holland posted this picture of her being
fitted for her Mia Dearden aka speedy
mask so let there be no question as to
which character that she's going to be
from the comics DC comics themselves
even posted on their website she's going
to be speedy so she'll be wearing this
mask sometime before the finale remember
last year Roy got his costume before the
finale to Batman always needs a Robin
fanatically I think it just works better
if Boyd eyes and Thea takes the mantle
yeah it's I mean it's really sad it's
huge bummer but there are negative
consequences to the choices that the
characters have made this year Marc
Guggenheim said that the show would
address some of the negative
consequences of really bad judgment
calls that the characters have made this
year in
what is a worse consequence than one of
your friends dying there have been some
leaked pictures of Roy wearing Oliver's
arrow suit I can't I can't post them
just for copyright reasons but in the
teaser for episode 16 racial goals says
the city will turn on you talking to
Oliver the big villain in episode 19 is
someone named death bolt he's being
played by Doug Jones
he played Abe Sapien and Hellboy if you
guys don't remember he's a pretty big
deal so he could be the one to kill Roy
while he's wearing Oliver's costume
thinking that he is Oliver just to be
clear that is all speculation that
doesn't mean that anyone's dying and if
Roy does die
just remember what happened to Jason
Todd in the comics he came back he was
resurrected as the Red Hood so Roy could
always come back in some weird twist
some story explanation there's no such
thing as final death in the comics Caity
Lotz is the best example of that so it's
always possible that Roy could go off on
the spin-off show on the all-star team
of show or he could just be leaving the
show because the actor wants to leave
the show or it could be a totally
different character it could be Quentin
who's in trouble here's my big question
for you guys
given that Marc Guggenheim has said that
they're going to have crazy WTF s way
crazier than Oliver being killed and
brought back to life do you feel like
all this evidence is pointing to them
doing a death in the family type moment
or do you think it's all a misdirect
speaking of mr. X let's talk Lazarus Pit
the producers have not explained WTF is
going on with cage lots coming back for
the all-star spin-off I don't know what
the title is yet I'm just gonna call it
all stars just because Justice Society
feels like it's a little out of bounds
all-star flare oh I would laugh so hard
if they named it all-star flare oh
there's no other gonna do that but they
could be bringing her back
Sarah bringing Sarah back in the like a
finale Lazarus Pit WTF moment that kind
of sounds like the topic of like another
bonus video so why don't I do that next
week I'll do like a Black Canary
Caity Lotz lazarus pit video be sure to
subscribe to get that I kind of want to
do a flash video tomorrow so I'm gonna
push like more arrow stuff to next week
why you guys wait for that flash stuff
you can click here to rewatch The
Avengers trailer a billion more times
it's so amazing just watch the vision
over and over and over and you can click
here to learn more about the arrow flash
spinoff thank you so much for watching
now let's all do the thing
you